herrmann wir stehen ja vor oder mitten
in der wohl größten flüchtlingswelle
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg sind sie im
moment wenn man das überhaupt so
formulieren kann zufrieden mit der
organisation mit der planung mit den
regelungen dieser flüchtlingswelle
zufrieden ist vielleicht zu viel gesagt
aber insgesamt schon zum einen sehr
dankbar für die großartige leistungen
vieler ehrenamtlich und hauptamtlich die
hier in den letzten wochen dazu
beigetragen haben dass wir die
flüchtlinge die nach deutschland
gekommen sind bislang ganz überwiegend
gut aufnehmen konnten das läuft muss man
ehrlich sagen obwohl es in dem kurzen
zeitraum mehr sind als selbst
2015/16
darin am anfang gekommen sind das läuft
wesentlich besser ich kann für bayern
jedenfalls sagen dass wir überhaupt
niemanden in einem zelt wie wir das
jetzt hier gerade sehen unterbringen
mussten wir haben alle im moment unter
einem
geschlossenen häusern manche
vorübergehend für ein zwei drei tage in
einer sporthalle aber alle anderen dann
den weiteren unterkünften ich sind
insgesamt allein vom erst zugang jahr
deutschlandweit 300.000 schon gekommen
davon 100.000 in bayern angekommen und
wir haben aktuell auf jeden fall schon
rund 60 bis 70 tausend wirklich gut
untergebracht die hälfte vielleicht in
privatunterkünften die anderen in
solchen staatlichen oder kommunalen
unterkunft und das ist schon eine
beachtliche leistung innerhalb von vier
wochen und ich glaube wir müssen damit
nicht zufrieden sein aber wir können
insgesamt schon dankbar dafür sein dass
wir so großartiges engagement und
ehrlich so großartige hilfsbereitschaft
in der deutschen bevölkerung haben immer
wenn ich diese oder eine ähnliche frage
den vergangenen wochen gestellt habe
antwortet die politik darauf das
ehrenamtliche engagement erst mal zu
loben und mein eindruck ist dass das
tatsächlich das ist was am allerbesten
funktioniert das was die bürgerinnen und
bürger hier im land machen wie sehr sie
sich tatsächlich engagieren für die
ukrainischen flüchtlinge aber
registrierung hat nicht funktioniert man
weiß gar nicht wie viel ukrainische
flüchtlinge sich auch nur annähernd im
land aktuell aufhalten und die
verteilung funktioniert auch nicht
da bin ich mit manchen dingen in den
ersten wochen endlich zufrieden gewesen
wir haben das ja zum beispiel beim bund
angemahnt dass eine vernünftige
verteilung stattfindet das ist in der
tat leider so dass zunächst die
bundesregierung die
bundesinnenministerium persönlich aber
auch andere mitglieder der
bundesregierung erklärt haben man könne
die gar nicht verteilen weil die völlig
frei sind natürlich sind das freie
menschen und natürlich wenn jemand sagt
ich will zu meinem onkel nach köln oder
zu einem bruder nach paris da dürfen die
darüber halb frei hinreisen aber sobald
sie staatliche leistungen in anspruch
nehmen dann haben wir nach der deutschen
gesetzeslage sehr wohl die möglichkeit
in deutschland zu verteilen deshalb
leider
wenig gedauert so erinnern sich das ja
auch die regierende bürgermeisterin von
berlin fragt natürlich angemahnt hat der
bund muss jetzt dass eine verteilung
vornehmen die können nicht alle in
berlin samt der münchner
oberbürgermeister von der spd hat gesagt
das kann nicht so sein dass die einen
ferrari so in münchen ankommen wir
müssen verteilt werden also ich habe
zwei drei wochen gedauert bis man das in
der bundesregierung kapiert hat jetzt
läuft das einigermaßen mit der
verteilung bei der registrierung haben
wir auch das problem dass hier zunächst
erklärt wort und ist ein nein die bürger
nicht registrieren oder sei eine
zumutung ich sage ganz klar ist aus
sicherheitsgründen unbedingt notwendig
dass alles so schnell wie möglich
registriert werden das ist zu deren
eigenen shops notwendig untersagen
inzwischen auch große karitative
organisationen wie die diakonie
deutschland das ist zum schutz der
betroffenen selbst wichtig dass sie
registriert werden zum beispiel wenn es
um den themen und zwangsprostitution
menschenhandel und dergleichen geht und
es ist aber auch für unser aller
sicherheit notwendig dass wir wissen wer
eigentlich in unserem land ist und wer
dann sozialleistungen kassieren will
herr kutschaty ihre innenministerin und
ihre senatoren und so weiter haben all
das verhindert nein haben sie überhaupt
nicht aber wir haben noch mal mit den
bürgerinnen und bürger aus der ukraine
eine andere rechtliche situation
sie sind eu-bürger sie können ohne visum
sich 90 tage lang in der europäischen
union aufhalten viele sind auch mit dem
pkw gekommen einfach über die grenze und
da können sie alles kontrollieren es
wären sie schon sagt die bundespolizei
und sagte auch joachim herrmann sie
halten nicht einander wenn einer im
privat pkw in die über die grenze kommt
das kriegen sie nicht kontrolliert sie
wollen nicht alle grenzen dichtmachen
innerhalb der europäischen union ist
wird an den außengrenzen der
europäischen union also an der grenze
zwischen der ukraine und polen genau
registriert wer kommt in die eu und
natürlich ist die bundespolizei in den
zügen mit unterwegs und schaut auch wer
da jetzt kommen und wir wissen schon
sehr genau wer jetzt alles kommt nämlich
überwiegend frauen mit ihren kindern die
auch bislang zu einem großen teil von
den anderen angehörigen sie sagen sie
wissen genau wer kommt aber sie haben
keine ahnung wie viele kommen das sind
ja so über den daumen gepeilt ja weil
die wir im moment habe ich jede
einreisen kann auch innerhalb der eu
sicher frei berlin und bern sie malen
genau wer kommt sie aber welche leute
welche leute wissen das ist zum
allergrößten teil über die kontrollen
dann auch in den zügen von der sie
wissen und dieses registriert haben da
können sie sagen während denen wissen
werden von denen die wir kontrollieren
können wissen wir dass auch ja aber das
macht ja nicht besser was ich jetzt
gerade sagen wir können nicht jedes mal
ehrlich wo man keine ahnung bekommen ist
bisher und man hat auch ich doch doch
stopp stopp stopp stopp magath werden
wir wissen schon von denjenigen die
gekommen sind die sich registrieren
lassen wäre das immer und haben wissen
aber daher habe man ganz kurz zum
faktencheck hier in der sendung die
bundesregierung spricht von der aktuell
sehr hohen dunkelziffer das heißt bei
einer dunkelziffer weiß man ja auch also
erstmal gar nicht wie hoch die s und man
weiß naturgegebene maßen auch gar nicht
ja wer sich dann darunter befindet das
ist ja logisch
es ist in der tat eine absolut
unbefriedigende situation
wir haben in bayern sehr nachdrücklich
darauf gedrungen dass die städte und
landkreise so schnell wie möglich
möglichst viele registrieren möglichst
alle registrieren wir haben aktuell nach
den meldungen unserer städte und
landkreise in bayern schon über
76.000 flüchtlinge in bayern die hier
registriert worden sind das merkwürdig
ist aber dass die bundesregierung sich
das bundesinnenministerium seit drei
wochen weigert und die unmittelbare
auskunft aus dem ausländerin
der zentralregister zu geben in denen
diese zahlen eigentlich alle eingepflegt
werden sollten die konkreten meldungen
was auch wichtig ist weil dann dort
nämlich eine automatische abgleich auch
mit dem verhandlungs datenbestand von
kriminellen und dergleichen auf
deutscher und europäischer ebene
stattfindet will man weigert sich und
setzt sie jeweils aktuellen zahlen zu
geben am beginn vor einem monat war das
kein problem da hatten wir einfach das
interesse zu erfahren wo sind denn die
ukrainer die schon lange hier leben im
land weil die dann natürlich die
potenziellen aufnehmer sein könnten für
jemand der private unterkommen wird da
haben wir innerhalb jeweils von 48
stunden alle aktuellen zahlen bekommen
so war das anfang märz seit drei wochen
weigert sich das bundesministerium uns
die jeweils aktuellen zahlen zu geben
damit ich auch überprüfen kann wie viele
sind den tatsächlich jetzt in bayern in
diesem ausländerzentralregister die
bundesregierung weigert sich aus mir
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbaren
gründen diese zahlen den ländern wie das
übrigens mehrere länder nicht nur bayern
sie auch gelernt hätten sie sagen nicht
nach und war für ihn das versuchen wir
kurz aufzuklären können sie antworten
warum macht ihre innenministerin die
gesamte registrieren links regierung
wird ja jetzt aufgebaut das ist das peak
system das dauert leider etwas auch mir
zu lange bis das alles mit der
registrierung mit der eintragung so
funktioniert aber ich möchte an einer
stelle sagen dass jetzt plötzlich
registrierung aller gewalt ganz sofort
und so schnell gefordert wird nur damit
keine sozialleistungen falsch kassiert
werden das im anblick dieser bilder die
wir gerade im ersten teil der sendung
gesehen haben versender die elemente
zahl der von jetzt herr maja drei
anlagen sozusagen das verletzt jetzt
natürlich schon wir haben gerade bilder
gesehen von menschen die brutal
umgebracht worden sind wir erleben
menschen die dafür aber jetzt ist eine
interessante rechnung der zeit wann
sozialbetrug hier also ich glaube es
geht um die reformierung der menschen
und nicht in der absicht
sozialleistungen zur kassa aber auch
rügen ich glaube ganz gehalten haben wir
gerade nicht gut aber was ist schon ein
starkes argument ganz kurz mit mit herrn
marquardt ein entscheidendes argument
hier nicht zu registrieren war erstmal
auch damit würde man die menschen
unnötig drangsalieren die können sich
frei bewegen die können ja einreisen
quasi wie touristen warum soll man dann
kontrollieren an in grenzen hat aber
doch auch zur folge dass man den
menschen in den ersten 90 tagen
überhaupt gar nicht helfen kann wenn man
nicht weiß dass sie hier sind
also erstmal muss man ja sagen der
eindruck der erweckt wird dass auch von
ehrlicherweise die wissen gar nicht mehr
kommt das ist nicht richtig es gibt
europäische fahndungsdaten banken
natürlich müssen die menschen wenn sie
aus der ukraine ausreisen erstmal aus
der ukraine aus reisen da gibt es
checkpoints und dann auch in einem eu
staat einreisen und dort werden sie
kontrolliert dort werden auch die
personalien kontrolliert und dann weiß
man wer in der europäischen union ist
das muss man dann auch nicht mit der
gleichen datenbank zwei stunden später
noch mal an der nächsten grenze machen
aber ist es so wenn sie es wissen wie
viele ukrainische flüchtlinge sind
aktuell in deutschland das ist in der
tat die frage die nicht gut zu
beantworten ist aber wir wissen
natürlich und wann man darf jetzt nicht
den eindruck erwecken dass man irgendwie
alle sozialleistungen bekommen natürlich
muss man sich um sozialleistungen ich
glaube dass die alle hier sind wir
sozialen und es ist auch so dass wir
genau wissen wie viele urlauber jetzt
gerade aus spanien in rumänien sind wir
wissen nicht wie viele gastarbeiter aus
rumänien gerade in deutschland sind das
sind auch keine besonders interessanten
informationen weil man muss glaube ich
beim wesentlichen bleiben und wenn sie
zu recht einfordern wie sollen mehr für
die ukraine tun dann auch im eigenen
land und zwar in der form dass wir jetzt
nicht mit einmal nebelkerzen werfen und
zu tun als die gebe es hier irgend ein
sicherheitsrisiko das sicherheitsrisiko
ist in der ukraine und wenn wir schaffen
das jetzt halbwegs unbürokratisch
hinzubekommen dass die menschen vor
diesen grausamen kriegen können dann
sind den schritt beiden ein mögliches
risiko sprechen wir gleich das habe ich
aber gar nicht benannt sondern mir ging
es um die hilfe dieser menschen ganz
konkret er das spielt sich auch an
unseren schulen hier in berlin gerade ab
man muss den menschen so schnell wie
möglich helfen und kann das aber gar
nicht weil die gar nicht festgestellt
worden dass die überhaupt hier sind frau
bär wie ist da ihre auffassung ist dass
ihre auffassung von freiheit das man
einmal sagt okay man lässt erst mal
kommen man weiß als staat gar nicht oder
in der eu gar nicht wer sich gerade hier
aufhält wie viele ukrainische
flüchtlinge sind 200.000 oder sind es
vielleicht schon 800.000 ist das auch
ihre auffassung von freiheit
also auf meiner sicht muss man erst
einmal festhalten das ja hier einst sehr
gut funktioniert haben was wir als
instrument das erste mal benutzt haben
erst einmal einreisen können dass wir
nicht irgendwie an der grenze menschen
aufhalten die vor krieg vor gewalt die
vor verfolgung fliehen sondern dass sie
erst einmal ein reißer können dann ist
natürlich zu einem späteren zeitpunkt
nein aber da an der stelle wird ja das
erste mal überprüft und da wissen sie
dann auch wer sich insgesamt in der
europäischen union befindet darauf hat
der kollege mark wird gerade schon
hingewiesen und das ist das erste mal
dass die eu hier eben in dieser art und
weise gemeinsam agiert so und jetzt geht
es darum weiter erstens zu registrieren
und zweitens zu verteilen diese
registrierung wird ja jetzt auch im eu
kontext abgestimmt aufgebaut das heißt
dass wir auch einen datenaustausch haben
zwischen den mitgliedstaaten wer ist wo
und wir machen angebote weg von der
grenze also aus den anrainerstaaten
polen tschechien slowakei ungarn die
alle sehr sehr viele flüchtlinge erst
einmal aufgenommen und untergebracht
haben hin nach deutschland innerhalb von
deutschland aber eben auch in anderen
mitgliedstaaten bis hin in die usa
präsident biden hat jetzt gerade dieses
angebot gemacht werden also jetzt auch
schon flüge direkt aus den grenz ländern
auch aus moldawien eingerichtet die eben
helfen dort vor ort zu entlasten die
menschen zu verteilen gleichzeitig aber
ein bisschen rücksicht auch darauf zu
nehmen wo haben sie verwandte wo haben
sie bekannte weil es eben auch große
ukrainische communitys über die
verschiedenen mitgliedsstaaten verteilt
bekommt und da bin ich ganz ehrlich
sollten wir die diskussion jetzt hier
nicht zu bürokratisch führen nicht
wieder diese typisch deutsche nabelschau
sondern wirklich pragmatisch zu packen
und es ist doch klar wenn ein kind in
der schule ankommen dass es da
registriert ist oder dass es in dem
moment dann registriert wird auch die
vielen tollen ehrenamtlichen helfer die
wir sehen auch die staatlichen
organisationen die hier unterstützen die
helfen doch dann bei der registrierung
die meisten ämter vor ort haben sich
doch darauf auch eingerichtet haben
entsprechende dolmetscher vor ort fragen
willst du hier bleiben willst du weiter
was momentan der schwierigkeiten macht
und das kann keiner von uns zur zeit
beantworten haben was die menschen
selber ja gar nicht wissen wie lange sie
bleiben werden und überhaupt wollen die
meisten wollten von der grenze geschafft
darüber sprechen wir gleich wo bleibt
weg dass sie das richtige ja wieder
zurückgehen sobald der krieg vorbei ist
nein aber ich glaube das ist da ist
jetzt hier momentan der lage nicht
angemessen der wir da gerade alle
miteinander in europäischen union wie
ich finde sehr tatkräftig begegnen und
das sollten wir doch dann auch gerade
angesichts dieser monströsen bilder aus
der ukraine stärker betonen als ob jetzt
hier der letzte datenabgleich irgendwo
nicht funktioniert hat hermann ist das
so herr marquardt hat ihn gerade gesagt
mensch also wie können sie angesichts
dieser bilder die wir vor allen dingen
von heute empfangen dort aus butscher
vor sozialmissbrauch waren das war die
frage von herrn marquardt gebe ich noch
mal in zur antwort weiter
das problem ist doch ein ganz anderes
offensichtlich hat herr kutschaty von
dem was realität in der bundesrepublik
deutschland diesem moment in solchen
dingen offensichtlich ziemlich wenig
ahnung die realität ist dass in seiner
vergangenheit ja sogar situation gegeben
hat wo deutsche bundesbürger kriminell
sich vorgegeben vorgegeben haben
asylbewerber zu sein um geld zu
kassieren
auch solche fälle gibt es wir haben
inzwischen die ersten teile wo jemand
mit gefälschten ukrainischen pässen
unterwegs ist und dergleichen das muss
doch kontrolliert werden es wird doch
keinem einzigen ukrainischen flüchtling
verwehrt in unser land zu kommen das ist
ein übrigens gut organisiertes land die
ukraine das ist nicht mehr wie ein
flüchtling aus den mittleren afrika oder
asien ist da auch lieber de maizière
spreche staatswesen gewohnt wir haben
keinen einzigen wir haben ich habe ich
eine einzige heimische flüchtlinge in
bayern erlebt er ein problem damit hatte
dass er sich entsprechend registrieren
lassen soll dass er seinen pass vorlegt
oder dergleichen die menschen selbst
haben überhaupt keine probleme es ist
ein problem der politik wenn etwas schön
in berlin die dafür zuständige
sozialsenatorin erklärt hat die anzeige
ist völlig überlastet dann wurde ihr
angeboten dass die polizei hilft bei der
registrierung dann hat katja kipping von
der linkspartei erklärt dass sie ihren
flüchtlingen nicht zuzumuten dass sie
von der polizei entsprechend registriert
werden was ist das für ein
staatsverständnis was ist das für ein
polizei verständnis der wagen war die
haben gerade geladen als hermann dingen
bei schon das von der deutschen politik
herr marquardt nein ich finde einfach
ganz generell wir müssen uns auch mal
ein bisschen an die eigene nase fassen
also wir können es auch die sitzen ja
hier in der bild -zeitung mal an die
eigene nase fassen die bode eigentlich
in den letzten jahren berichtet welche
schwerpunkte wohnen gesetzt und da
gibt's zum beispiel studien der 79 der
berichterstattung über zuwanderung
negativ ist ja und in der bild zeitung
dass es aber auch so ist das zum
beispiel über straftaten von
asylsuchenden von gefürchteten 30 mal
häufiger in der zeitung berichtet wird
als es im statistischen anteil
entspricht an der kriminalstatistik und
diese zahlen kann man ja dann auf sich
wirken lassen was dabei am ende glaube
ich rauskommt ist dass man natürlich
über einzelfälle reden kann dass man
gucken kann wie kann man die aufarbeiten
aber man muss auch den blick für das
ganze mal wieder haben wir haben jetzt
eine unglaubliche situation in der
ukraine wir haben aber in der
europäischen union auch eine situation
in der wir wirklich mehrere millionen
menschen kurzfristig aufnehmen müssen
und das auch können man hat in den
vergangenen jahren den eindruck erweckt
das boot ist voll ich saß im november wo
sie gleich gesagt haben eine neue
flüchtlingskrise über 1000 am tag aus
belarus und so weiter da wird manchmal
so eine krise herbei geredet die wir
glaube ich simuliert haben in den
letzten jahren wir haben viele
möglichkeiten jetzt muss man sich mit
der neuen situation abfinden leider und
das ist bei joachim herrmann ja auch so
dass die cdu/csu lange in der regierung
war leider haben wir nicht die
strukturen um sehr schnell auf solche
großen flüchtlingszahlen reagieren zu
können das muss man jetzt eben
nacharbeiten aber da finde ich ist jetzt
ein parteipolitisches ping pong was da
katja kipping wäre sagt wie wo was nicht
so richtig wichtig joachim herrmann hat
glaube ich in bayern genug zu tun und
ich wünsche ihm dabei viel erfolg und
ich hoffe auch dass in berlin das bald
an gut läuft ich staune gerade wie sie
darauf reagieren wir saßen tatsächlich
zuletzt ende vergangenen jahres hier wir
hatten in diesen tagen als wir damals
zusammen saßen tatsächlich eine massive
flüchtlingskrise die hat sich vor allen
dingen dadurch ausgedrückt dass da
tatsächlich tausende am zaun zur eu
standen und das sich an diesem zaun ein
wahres drama abgespielt hat das haben
die bilder von damals ja auch
transportiert und wir haben damals ganz
sachlich darüber diskutiert wie der eu
handeln muss und sie hat infolgedessen
ja auch gehandelt dort an diesem zaun
von polen nach belarus damals sie haben
uns vorgeworfen probleme zu benennen in
diesen flüchtlings
vorgeworfen dass die aufgabe von
journalisten aus weiter bleibt wie vor
ist stände immer missstände auch zu
benennen war und ist es die frage das
ging übrigens gerade von beiden herren
minister aus und nicht von der bösen
bild zeitung bei als innenminister hat
gerade gesagt und das lassen sie uns das
ganz nüchtern hier analysieren oder
diskutieren ob das der fall ist dass es
massenhaft bereits nicht nur in
einzelfällen einen missbrauch gibt von
menschen die diese flüchtlingsbewegung
aus der ukraine für ihre zwecke
ausnutzen illegal ausnutzen das war ein
vorwurf gerade von bayerns innenminister
lk die ist dass ihr eindruck in
nordrhein-westfalen aktuell ich bin erst
mal ziemlich entsetzt von der äußeren
von hermann wir sehen diese grausamen
bilder und er spricht jetzt als erstes
hier von missbrauch und sozialmissbrauch
ist ja auch vorhin von ihnen genannt
worden ich will es noch mal sagen ohne
registrierung gibt es auch keine
sozialleistung was soll da missbraucht
werden also das geht ja hinten und vorne
nicht auf als der kollege hermann da
gerade gesagt hat wenn man registriert
jetzt muss man auch genau sagen wo man
herkommt wer man ist und dann ist es
auch völlig richtig dass man anspruch
auf die entsprechende leistung hat auf
unterkunft die kinder in die schule
gehen können oder in die kita das wollen
wir alles auch organisieren